how does an actor get presence you
always hear that oh this person gave
such a performance with presents how
does that happen is that something
that's going certain people possess it's
a good question i think it's it has to
do with living your life and how you
live your life and your generosity of
spirit who you are as a person you know
how you deal with situations in your
life stressful situations and how do you
come through you know who you are that's
what gives you presents you don't think
there's a class they can teach you
presents I mean there's presence in
terms of you know being in the moment
and showing up which you know you can
achieve by doing some lot of different
meditation exercises which is great
because that also plugs you into you
know the true part of yourself some real
authenticity in yourself with the
presence when you set presents where
that took me to is like a real person
that shows up not like present being in
the moment and not thinking about
something else which of course that's
important too but something that extra
thing you know that really that you walk
in with the whole person not just parts
of you that every you know particle of
your being shows up somewhere
you